hey guys it is the 14th of May my name
is Jess MacDonald and you're watching
games but news may contain nuts wow
these intros are really going downhill
I'm sure they'll be interviewing to my
replacement soon after story of the day
is something of a correction because it
turns out there was a really good reason
for the comment about watch dogs being
1080p being removed from the PlayStation
site it's because it's not in 1080p at
all in fact it's going to be 900 P on
ps4 and 792p on Xbox one and both will
run at 30 frames per second to the upset
gamers or those who are now turning a
favorable eye toward the PC version
Ubisoft creative director Jonathan
Lauren says resolution is just a number
just like framerate is just a number but
you make choices about the experience
you want to deliver in our case dynamism
is everything exploration and expression
and everything you want to have a steady
framerate but you want to have dynamism
at the core of the experience the same
goes with resolution let me know if
you're in the camp of caring not caring
or you were gonna get it on PC
anyway personally I'm all for that last
option next up Microsoft have had a
bunch of things to say about what they
expect the outcomes of the Kinect las'
Xbox one will be so let's roll them all
up in the next minute or so firstly Xbox
is Phil Spencer reckons that the move
will actually lead to more connects
being sold as an explanation of the
somewhat strange logic Spencer said he
thinks the lower price point will lead
to more people picking up Xbox ones but
ultimately wanting to grab a Kinect as
well to fill out the experience
elsewhere in-house Microsoft to use of
meting has said that the company is a
pioneer with Kinect and that in five
years we'll be laughing at any computer
that doesn't have a us with voice alone
he added that he thinks bundling the
Kinect with the Xbox one at launch was
the right call because it is words in
the beginning of a new console
generation you're trying to set the bar
for a new experience and I think we did
that with Xbox one the last thing worth
mentioning is that Microsoft are in
talks with publishers about whether the
removal of the Kinect could free up
processing power to have more games at
10
ATP Microsoft is again weighed in on why
they reckon the ps4 is outselling the
Xbox one and you'll have to let me know
if you agree or not yes of Medi has said
that Sony has the ps4 in 40-plus markets
while the Xbox one is only in 13
although this gap is set to close
significantly in September when
Microsoft's console will hit Japan and
25 other regions
another reason they've expressed is that
people have been more satisfied with the
Xbox 360 down the ps3 so in that respect
people have less money to upgrade in the
short term due to regular updates for
the Xbox 360 let me know if you agree
with this reasoning or if you have a
whole of theory in that commenting
section down below or you can chat to me
on my Twitter where I'm at just
MacDonnell those are all the things that
I have to tell you about today but
tomorrow I'll have a bunch of more
things and stuff so I hope to see them